good morning believe nation today's
message is you are in control of
everything that happens over to you
robert herjavec awake TV go people
always think there's a finality to
success you know people think about
success in terms of a finish line people
was asked me why are you so successful
and always correct them and I say I'm
not successful you know the minute you
think you've made it is the beginning of
the end so it's just about the overall
message is you got to keep going you got
to love what you do when you gotta keep
going why because what's the alternative
what's the alternative why were we put
on this earth where we put on this earth
to be miserable and to complain and and
to look at life as victims I and then
control of everything that happens to me
everything everything that will happen
in my life I will be the master that
doesn't mean my life will always be
happy that doesn't mean my life will
always be good but I have the ultimate
choice to choose how I would react to
the things that happen to me and move
forward from that and I'm okay with not
succeeding at them because the journey
on that road is worth it for me so I'm
not sure I would go as far to say that
you are in control of everything that
happens to you but I totally agree that
you are in control of how you react to
things and I think too many people are
where they are too many entrepreneurs
are where they are and not and you're
not achieving more you're not achieving
your dreams your big goals because
you're not taking that accountability
you're not taking that responsibility
you're too busy blaming other people
you're out there saying I'm not where I
want to be because of the country that I
live in or the education I don't
have or the parents that I have or I
don't have enough money or I don't have
whatever the excuse is that you're
telling yourself and there's been a lot
of people who have done way more have
gone way further in their career have
accomplished much bigger goals in what
you have set up for yourself and started
with less than what you already have now
the difference is they took action they
believe in themselves they stop blaming
the people in the world around them they
recognize that they were in control of
how they reacted to things they bet on
themselves and they made it happen so
the question of the day today is are you
in control of what happens to you I'm
curious to know what you think leave in
the comments below I'm going to join a
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and i'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events presso
expresso